more than 26 million people have used
at-home DNA kits but finding out about
your family's past can still be a
difficult and time-consuming process
that's where Eric Schubert comes in the
18 year old ancestry amateur has helped
hundreds of people fill in their family
trees we've been following him for a few
months asking him to shoot video diaries
of the process and as you'll see the
results are nothing less than
life-changing let's just see if you tell
me nothing let's see what happens so
your dad's Ross Miller yeah yeah that's
just what was on my Facebook page so
that was easy to watch Eric Schubert on
the hunt don't count me out yet I won 15
seconds booth is to watch someone who's
found his groove here's a half card the
New Jersey teen has become something of
a genealogy expert she's born in Daytona
Beach
June 2nd 1893 Wow
in just over five minutes he used Google
public records census data and newspaper
clippings to track my family back to the
19th century your great-grandfather so
this is 1817 in Georgia how hard is this
to do anybody can do it it just takes a
lot of practice at around 10 years old
Schubert started digging into his own
family's past as a cure for boredom now
at 18 he estimates he's helped more than
a thousand people find their roots
two big puzzles that you just have to
look at all the pieces and put together
he often takes just days to find the
answers his clients have been searching
for for decades both parents and the
twin thing is correct
really Eric it's been like 24 hours I
what took so long where do you start
uh it honestly depends like if someone's
adopted they can't find their parents
names but they got non-identifying info
from the state your mother was 26 she
was a homemaker
your father was an auto mechanic he was
26 and to some people it looks like
nothing but ten
with paired with the DNA results it's
easy as pie what maybe pie for Schubert
is deeply meaningful to the people he
helps like Kate DeSantis I've gone
through my life not looking like anyone
you know and to see a picture of my
birth mother and then to find out I have
siblings and I look like I belong and it
was overwhelming for Schubert this side
job requires hours a day pursuing a
dozen cases while juggling his full-time
job high school you're somewhat pardon
the expression a little obsessed with
this outre I embrace it sounds to me
like he really pours himself into it as
a mom does that it all worried you yes
because I also want him to enjoy life
but he is the kid that you'll find home
in his room working on a case because
that's just what he wants to do much of
the work he does for free but when he
does charge clients it's often under
$100 private investigators have paid a
lot of money to do this yeah it's insane
I mean people should have a right to
this stuff you know if you're adopted
especially so you shouldn't have to pay
twenty five hundred dollars to figure
out your family history or find out
family roots Schubert has worked with
people all over the country but he found
perhaps his most fulfilling case much
closer to home like I've known you for
so long like how did I not know you were
adopted about a year ago he helped his
friend Sammy Lynam find her biological
mother but her mom wanted no contact it
hurts that she doesn't want to get to
know me but like I respect that it's her
decision and I can only do so much - are
you really okay with that
I mean
she's just not in a good state and I
don't want to be a part of something
that could hurt me
do you feel like there's anybody who can
understand what you're feeling right now
Eric for the most part why he's been
with me on the entire journey and he
knows like all the stories and
everything I tell him everything a few
months ago Lynam mustered up the courage
to dig into her father's side she's won
last name whoo-whee it's a business card
with the name who we think has to be her
father her uncle a picture of the person
I'm looking for somewhere it's the
Internet 30 minutes later he found
Lionel's dad and more hi jasmine my name
is Sammy and I'm reaching out because I
think we are half-siblings our camera
was there the first time Lynam met her
half-sister Jasmine Underhill
when you saw each other's faces you saw
each other live yeah so cool we kind of
Li clicked right away yeah yeah I
thought it was gonna be super awkward
I'm like I'm prepared for like weird
moments of silence yeah it wasn't though
we just kept talking yeah Lynam is also
going to be a knot for the first time
Underhill is having a baby I just
remember the texts like Sammy's saying
like oh my god like I'm gonna be a name
when I told her you know what the gender
was and she freaked out and she's like I
called it I called it was a boy it's
that excitement the potential for a
happy ending that drives Shubert every
time so I'm gonna call this case closed
and he looks at it just like that is a
mystery to be solved
he has been inundated so much so he set
up a Facebook page chest for helping
people or answering some of the calls
he's now again but he does really
literally changes people's life it
really does yeah and I love how he said
people should have a right to this yeah
I'm glad you show besides too it doesn't
always work out one of those adopted
kids but then for her to be able to find
some happiness there I've seen pretty
amazing